♪ ♪
>> Greg: SO WHAT WILL
$1 BILLION GET YOU?
AN ISLAND.
>> IN SOMALIA, THEY HAVE 100% TO
40.
AND MICHAEL BLOOMBERG GETS VOTES
TO SOMALIA.
>> Greg: CONGRATULATIONS, YOU
AREN’T AT BUT WHAT A PRICE TAG.
THE POLITICAL VERSION OF MOVIE
POPCORN.
HE SPENT ENOUGH TO FEED EVERYONE
IN THE CITY OF SOUTH BEND,
INDIANA MAYOR PETE’S HOME TOWN
FOR TWO YEARS.
MILLIONS FOR DELEGATES TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE HE WAS BETTER
THAN TRUMP.
IF YOU SEE SOME IMPORTANT DUDE
WITH A TOUPEE BUYING GUYS AT THE
BAR DRINKS, HE IS A CONSULTANT.
HE HAS LOST HIS NEW PORSCHE.
LESSONS ABOUND FROM HE PROVES
MONEY TALKS, CONSIDERING HIS
PERSONA, HIS CASH STILL GOT HIM
NEARLY TO THE FRONT LINE.
WHO KNOWS IF HE HAD SKIPPED THAT
DEBATE.
THAT IS THE OTHER LESSON.
MONEY CAN BUY YOU VOTES, BUT NOT
A PERSONALITY.
ULTIMATELY, YOU ARE STILL STUCK
WITH THIS.
>> I REALLY AM SURPRISED THAT
ALL OF THESE IN MY FELLOW
CONTESTANTS UP HERE, I GUESS,
WOULD BE THE RIGHT WORD FOR IT,
EVEN THOUGH NOBODY PAYS
ATTENTION TO THE CLOCK, I’M
SURPRISED THEY SHOW UP BECAUSE I
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT AFTER I DID A
GOOD JOB BEATING THEM LAST WEEK
THEY WOULD BE AFRAID TO DO THAT.
YOU TALK ABOUT 40 DEMOCRATS, 21
OF THOSE WERE PEOPLE I SPENT
$100 MILLION TO HELP ELECT.
I GOT THEM.
>> WE HAVE A VERY FEW,
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS.
LET ME FINISH.
>> HOW MANY?
>> NONE OF THEM ACCUSED ME OF
DOING ANYTHING OTHER THAN MAYBE
THEY DIDN’T LIKE THE JOKE I
TOLD.
THE THREE AND LET’S NOT
FORGET --
>> Kennedy: CAN I HAVE MONEY?
>> Greg: LET’S NOT FORGET A
UNIQUE WAY OF EATING PIZZA,
LICKING EACH FINGER.
I HAVEN’T PENNED THIS GROSSED
OUT SINCE I WAS WALKING ON MY
GRANDPARENTS.
[LAUGHTER]
THEN THERE IS LIZ WHO COULDN’T
WIN HER OWN STATE.
THAT’S LIKE YOUR FAMILY GOING ON
VACATION WITHOUT YOU.
AND LEAVING HER WITH ONE POWWOW
COOKBOOK AND 365 IDENTICAL BLACK
SHIRTS.
THE LESSON HERE COME AMERICA’S
PRETTY GOOD WITH THIS DISCERNING
PHASE.
LIZ COULD NOT SHAKE NEW
DECEPTIONS AND EACH FLY A NEW
TWIST.
NO WONDER HER CONSTITUENTS HAVE
RESERVATIONS FOR A WOMAN WHO
FALSELY CLAIMED HER ANCESTORS
LIVED ON ONE APPEARANCE LAST
NIGHT THE DEMS CHOSE A COMFY
SWEATER OVER IDENTITY POLITICS,
MONEY AND A SOCIALIST.
COULD THE PARTY PRIMLY HAVE
GROWN UP?
NO, ALL THEY DID IS REACH OLD
AGE.
JOE, JUAN WHAT SUCKS ABOUT
DROPPING OUT WE WILL NOT SEE THE
BLOOMBERG/TRUMP MATCHUP THAT WE
WANTED BECAUSE IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN GREAT.
>> Juan: IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING, RIGHT?
WE LIVE IN A POPULIST AGE AS WE
TALK ABOUT, MAYBE SANDERS IS A
MIRROR OF TRUMP.
ACTUALLY BLOOMBERG WOULD HAVE
BEEN AN MIRROR TO TRUMP.
I DON’T KNOW IF THE POPULIST
BASE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WOULD HAVE TAKEN TO HIM THE WAY
THE PUBLIC FACE OF THE G.O.P.
TOOK TO TRUMP.
BUT I WILL SAY TO ME, LOOKING
BACK ON BLOOMBERG’S CAMPAIGN, NO
ONE CAN DEFY THE PRIMARY
PROCESS.
THEY DISK DECIDE TO SKIP THE
FIRST FOUR CONTEST.
>> LIKE GIULIANI?
>> Juan: OBVIOUSLY, MAYBE
SOMEBODY IN THE FUTURE IS ABLE
TO DO IT AGAIN WITH A LOT OF
MONEY BUT IT DID NOT WORK.
>> Greg: KENNEDY I WAS
THINKING WHEN I WAS DOING THIS,
LIZ WAS REALLY THE ONE THAT TOOK
OUT BLOOMBERG.
>> Kennedy: YES.
>> Greg: SHE PULLED A CARRIGAN
IF THAT’S WHAT YOU WANT TO CALL
IT.
>> Kennedy: SHE WILL HURT
HERSELF WITH PROGRESSIVES IF SHE
STAYS IN BECAUSE SHE WAS THERE
FOR TWO REASONS.
BOTH OF THOSE REASONS TO PROTECT
JOE BIDEN.
SHE HAS PROMISED HER ALLEGIANCE
TO THE DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
PROCESS BECAUSE SHE HAS NEEDED
THEY WERE SUPPORT.
AND SHE STAYED IN IN ORDER TO
POKE A FEW MORE HOLES IN
BLOOMBERG, NOT THAT THAT NEEDED
TO HAPPEN AFTER LAST NIGHT, BUT
ALSO, TO TAKE SOME VOTES AWAY
FROM BERNIE.
SO YOU KNOW, HOW WOULD BERNIE
HAVE DONE IN MASSACHUSETTS HAD
SHE DROPPED OUT BEFORE SUPER
TUESDAY?
IT IS PRETTY CLEAR THAT HE WOULD
HAVE HAD A GREATER DELEGATE HALL
HAD SHE AND I’M WONDERING IF NO
ONE OMAR SENT OUT A NASTY TWEET
LAST NIGHT AND SQUARELY
ELIZABETH WARREN AND I’M
WONDERING IF SHE SHARES
THAT VICTORY OVER WITH MORE
PROGRESSIVES WHO RELATE NOW WANT
NOTHING TO DO WITH HER.
>> Greg: OH, BROTHER AS I LIKE
TO SAY.
JESSIE, YOU ALMOST FORGOT YOUR
NAME.
>> Jesse: JESSE WATTERS.
>> Greg: YES.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
THINKING NOW ABOUT BLOOMBERG OR
LIZ.
>> Jesse: I’M THINKING YOU BUY
AN ISLAND, YOU SHOULD GET TO
LIVE THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
THE BIGGEST CON JOB OF ALL
TIMES.
BLOOMBERG CAMPAIGN HAD SEVEN
FULLY PAGED STAFFERS LIVING IN
AMERICA’S IMOLA FOR THREE
MONTHS.
>> Greg: REALLY?
>> Jesse: I HAVE TO SEE THAT
EXPENSE REPORTS.
THAT HAS TO BE THE BEST JUNKET
OF ALL TIME.
THERE ARE 40,000 VOTERS IN
SOMALIA.
THEY ONLY GOT 175 OF THEM TO
VOTE FOR MIKE BLOOMBERG WHAT THE
HELL WERE THEY DOING FOR THREE
MONTHS?
>> PARTING.
>> Jesse: BLOOMBERG DID NOT
EVEN MISS $1 BILLION.
THIS HAS TO BE A HUGE CON JOB.
YOU GET 70% OF THE AD BUY.
THE ATTIC I COME I’M NOT GOING
TO SAY HIS NAME, MADE
$40 MILLION.
I WILL NOT SAY HIS NAME, YOU
KNOW, EX-GIRLFRIENDS OR PRETEND
FAMILY MEMBERS KNOCKING AT HIS
DOOR WITH THEIR HANDS OUT, BUT
HE COULD.
EVERYBODY KNEW THIS GUY DID NOT
HAVE THE POLITICAL TALENT TO
PULL THIS OFF.
HE CAN’T READ A PROMPTER, HE IS
WORSE THAN I WILL OWL SHARPTON.
HIS VOICE IS WORSE THAN LIZ
WARREN AND ACTUALLY WORSE THAN A
SEA TURTLE.
I WAS WATCHING HIS SPEECH LAST
NIGHT.
READY?
HE READ THIS COME I WANT TO PUT
THE UNITED BACK IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
EVEN BETO O’ROURKE WOULD HAVE
TOSSED THAT LINE OUT HERE THAT
IS NOT GOOD MATERIAL!
[LAUGHTER]
I CAN’T BELIEVE THIS GUY AND YOU
LAUGH ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: KATIE, DO YOU CARE TO
ADD ANYTHING?
>> Katie: WE WILL NEVER SOLVE
THE BOX CONTROVERSY.
THE BOX WHETHER
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG COME WITH A
BOX TO DEBATE PRESIDENT TRUMP,
BUT EVERYTHING IS MAKING A
PRETTY BIG DEAL OUT OF
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG BACKING
JOE BIDEN.
CONGRATULATIONS, THE GUY WHO WIN
175 VOTES IN SOMALIA IS BACKING
YOU IN THE ENDORSING YOU.
GOOD LUCK BUT MAYBE SOME MONEY
WILL BE HELPFUL BUT IN TERMS OF
MOVEMENT, GRASSROOTS SUPPORT FOR
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG, IT DOES NOT
EXHIBIT DON’T EXIST.
SO DO NOT THINK ON THAT.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG PARTICIPATING
IN THE TOWN HALL WITH FOX, HE
COMPLETELY EXPOSED HIMSELF AS AN
ELITIST WHO BELIEVES HE KNOWS
BETTER THAN YOU AND THAT HE’S
GOING TO TELL YOU HOW YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO LIVE YOUR LIFE
WHILE HE GETS TO DO WHATEVER HE
WANTS.
HE USED TO BE THIS FIGURE THAT
NOBODY REALLY HAD A MODERATE
APPEAL TO.
I THINK HE COMPLETELY EXPOSED
HIMSELF AS THE OPPOSITE.
AND NO SELF AWARENESS.
>> Kennedy: LICKING HIS
FINGERS AND PUTTING THAT HAPPY
PIZZA SLICE BACK IN THE BOX.
FINGER LICKING VIDEO.
>> Juan: DIDN’T YOU VOTE FOR
HIM AS A REPUBLICAN?
>> Jesse: I WAS NOT LIVING IN
NEW YORK CITY AT THE TIME BUT
NICE ONE, JUAN.
A STUPID QUESTION YOU CAN LAUGH
AT ME COME AMERICAN SAMOA, IS
THERE ANOTHER ONE?